Ну якщо ви подивитись, то зовні це паркан,
а всередині – це електростанція.
За освітою історик, а за покликом бізнесмен, Андрій
вирішив інвестувати в домашню сонячну електростанцію.
Він пишається результатом. Та шлях до цього
був з перепонами: його станцію з лютого до червня
не підключали до мережі.
Я міг добувати сонячну енергію ще в лютому місяці,
однак в Обленерго мені розповідали, ось почекайте,
ось через тиждень... І так дійшло до того, що вже
в квітні місяці нічого не відбувається.
Попри бюрократію, бажаючих заробити на сонці більшає.
Лише за останні півроку кількість домашніх
сонячних електростанцій зросла з тисячі до півтори.
В сонячну енергетику інвестує і великий бізнес.
Як приклад, ця станція у Київській області. На 13 га -
понад 22 тисячі панелей.
Утім такий "сонячний бум"
на загальний енергоринок України не впливає.
Частка енергії, добутої від сонця, - менше 1%.
Думаю, що тут важливо не кількість, а динаміка.
Даже мала кількість цих малих генераторів показує
динаміку, куди ми рухаємось. Це вже буде
дзвіночком для великих гравців.
В енергетичній стратегії уряду – амбітні цілі:
11% енергії з відновлювальних джерел до 2020 року,
25% - до 2035-го. Щоб привабити інвесторів з-за кордону,
держава зобов’язалася закуповувати цю енергію за
«зеленим тарифом» - від 10 до 17 євроцентів кВт/год,
залежно від джерела. Це чимало, адже, наприклад,
у ОАЕ, Чилі, Мексиці  енергії сонця коштує в середньому 2-3 центи.
Крім того, ще треба перемогти на аукціоні,
запропонувавши державі найвигідніші умови.
В Україні звичайно ми вже усвідомлюємо,
що нам потрібно розглядати можливість
розроблення законодавства, яке буде передбачати систему аукціонів.
Але на цьому етапі нам для того щоб відкрито спілкуватись
з нашими інвесторами, вітчизняними і іноземними
треба зберегти систему зелених тарифів.
«Зелені тарифи» зробили свою справу. На ринок
хочуть зайти Китай, Корея, а Саудівська Аравія
вже веде перемови про оренду понад сотні гектарів
на Вінниччині. Півсотні компаній подали заявки
на будівництво сонячних електростанцій в Зоні відчуження.
Андрій вже рахує прибутки від виробництва сонячної енергії.
Гривень 400 до кінця дня я отримаю.
Завдяки «зеленому тарифу» прибуток сталий,
а інфляція йому не загрожує.
Тож Андрій планує наростити потужності.